في اليوم الثالث من ازمه انتخاب رئيس جديد
لمجلس النواب الامريكي تخطى المجلس عدد
جولات التصويت التسعه التي كانت قد انهت
ازمه مماثله قبل 100 عام
في جولات متكرره من التصويت حملت نفس
النتيجه اخفق كافا مقعدي زعيم الجمهوريين
في مجلس النواب الامريكي من تامين الاصوات
المطلوبه كي يكون رئيسا لكن بالتزامن مع
ذلك كان هناك مفاوضات مغلقه بين انصار
لمارتي وعدد من النواب المعارضين تم تسريب
والحديث عن تنازلات قدمت لهم خلال تلك
المفاوضات منها متعلقه مثلا في سحب الثقه
من رئيس المجلس حين ينتخب مما اثار الكثير
من التساؤلات حول الصلاحيات والسلطات التي
قد تعطى لهذه المجموعه مقابل الحصول على
دعمها لكي يترقص في المجلس همم
بالتزامن ايضا مع ذلك كله يتواصل تعطيل
وشلل عمل مجلس النواب احد اهم مفاصل الحكم
في الولايات المتحده مما يعرقل سن اي
تشريعات عقد جلسات استماع وان يؤدي هذا
المجلس دوره الرقابي وهو كان احد الامور
او الوعود الانتخابيه التي تعهد بها
الجمهوريون للناخبين بان يمارس دور
الرقابه على اداره الرئيس بايدا كما يهدد
هذا التعطيل حتى صرف رواتب بعض الموظفين
ان استمر اضافه الى ذلك هذا التعطيل ساهم
ايضا في بروست تحضرات من مجموعه من
المشارعين الجمهوريين الذين سيتسلمون لجان
مفصليه كشؤون الخارجيه والخدمات المسلحه
والاستخبارات يحذرون من ان تعطل عمل
المجلس وشلاله يمثل تهديدا على الامن
القومي الامريكي خصوصا اذا برزت ازمه تهدد
هذا الامن بالتزامن مع شلل مجلس النواب
ايضا الكتله المعارضه تقدمت في ثالث ايام
هذه الازمه باسم جديد كي همم ينقسم الصوت
المعارض بين مرشحين جمهوريين ولكن ظل
المعارضون في نفس المقعد المعطل ولكن الذي
لا يتيح لهم هم ايضا تامين الاصوات
المطلوبه كي يكون مرشحهم هو رئيس مجلس
النواب في حين وصل الديمقراطيون التصويت
ككتله موحده لي زعيمهم حكيم جفريز